what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation we're gonna watch Wednesday episode
thrust today John how are you I am super spooky
and super excited how are you that's a great
answer I like to hear it I'm doing well myself
thank you for asking ladies and gentlemen
you know what to do please go ahead and leave
a like it makes you feel better and it makes
us feel better so please go ahead and do it
also subscribe and click the notification
Bell to get notified when our next reaction
for Wednesday is up here on the show now and
as always full-length Reaction watch alongs
where you sync it with your own copy of Wednesday
you can find over at our patreon page for
super sexy rejects we cover plenty of stuff
exclusively over there as well but what I
really wanted to mention today is that the
real rejects have recently partnered up with
a channel called geek that is g-i-q-u-e and
John and I we both know the owner of this
channel so it was something that we were very
much excited to be partnering up with and
essentially what geek offers is these one
minute video character origin stories and
other pop culture related content best part
is it's from a wide variety of creators I
myself have a video up there talking about
Nightwing koi genre has two videos up there
himself and it was something we were excited
to get the word out on because not only is
it a great place to get some extra nerdy content
if you yourself are a Creator hoping to make
some extra bucks or just looking for some
extra exposure you can join the geek community
and potentially get paid to produce a one
minute short yourself it'd be great if you
guys can subscribe to them because in a platform
that has a lot of competition it's great to
be a part of a platform that encourages Community
a communal experience and that's a major part
of why we agreed to be working with them anyway
guys let's watch Wednesday episode 3 right
now
bag over my head for optimal disorientation
wrists tie tight enough to cut off circulation
that rhymes you're in an escape room you can
take the mask off Bianca Dan that was fast
my hopes were dashed Against The Rock's bitter
disappointment my foe was no psychotic killer
or like a bunch of high school clowns it's
like every one of them the nightshades are
an elite Social Club emphasis on Elite we
have roof parties campouts she makes a killer
virgin mojito you can get pretty wild yeah
I bet so Weems looks the other way as long
as nobody makes any waves someone like Rowan
we booted that loser last semester what are
we going to do with her have her join I said
we invited a pledge after the crap she pulled
in the Poke up there's no way in hell the
crap she pulled she won there are no rules
in the pokeup let me save you the trouble
I'm not interested in joining you're seriously
turning us down can you believe it I feed
myself five minutes ago [Laughter] temperatures
like you who give kidnapping a bad name [Laughter]
oh [Music] so is woe included in every title
must be if I'm going to be responsible for
nevermore's demise the question is why am
I sharing this apocalypse with a pilgrim
the pilgrim world maybe you're stopping the
Pilgrims from rinking the apocalypse report
for their volunteer jobs at 10 A.M sharp I
trust you will all put your best face forward
of that makeup I got Pilgrim Road what'd you
get your eyes heat whatever that is it's weird
creepy antique store you'll love it though
Austin I caught your rooftop serenade the
other night I volunteered you to accompany
the Jericho High School marching band at the
ceremony oh God for the last time Rowan was
expelled everyone saw him leave have you spoken
to him since I texted him a few times but
I've never heard back or he's dead I don't
know why you care so much it's not like you
knew the guy I'm not sure why you care so
little good question he didn't seem surprised
when I showed you this last night you've seen
it before haven't you you drew it yeah a couple
days before the Harvest Festival it was open
on Rowan's desk so I just assumed he stole
it after we kicked him out of the nightshades
come on it's suspicious man you kind of went
ballistic on me it's unbelievable
with telekinesis these are typical Rowan and
what the hell is crack Stone doing the picture
with you you know who that is it's Joseph
crackstone it's like Jericho's founding father
it's kind of a big deal around here yeah look
oh wow he's everywhere genocide and turkey
dinners still got something lurking in the
woods no doubt connected to that school come
on will you stop pointing fingers at Nevermore
we're just doing my job looking out for the
well-being of our town boss before the good
citizens of Jericho elected me mayor I used
to wear that badge remember oh you probably
know more than you're letting on what a fake
ass smile switch volunteer assignments
things sneak to peek at his assignment but
if you're not into it no oh my God you you're
the best that's making lemonade and lemons
[Music] I hope Netflix has an event where
you can go to Pilgrim world that's what I
want over never world I'm mistress Arlene
a real oh not Emily Blunt original colonist
for 1625 to Jericho's first Pilgrim settlement
how fun this color scheme looks the most like
Adam's Family yeah the meeting house inside
is a collection of artifacts facts related
to Jericho's most beloved beloved Joseph kraxto
and Beyond is our privy America's first gender-neutral
restroom oh Progressive grab a uniform and
a box and make our forefathers proud are these
for muscling tourists [Music] [Laughter] local
artist scoop that fella up right here on Route
22. you're telling me someone actually goes
out and collects Road Caitlyn turns them into
that Dahmer ethical taxidermist well had the
weather rain I want us to pick you up something
I don't need to pay for that overpriced hipster
swill I'm brewing chaga you got kombucha in
the back as well take off that beanie show
us your snake hair conditions [Laughter]
thank you are not one of you from Bavaria
girl outfit kind of looks good on her check
out this greedy little freak please I
[Music]
wowie wow dude you could have aimed at elsewhere
come here we're gonna cut your head off howdy
programs let him go what do you want to end
up in the stocks too remember what happened
the last time we did this dance
sweep the leg Wednesday
you dumbass and here you will remain for 40
days thank you for your generous donation
to my re-election campaign considered a token
of our ongoing cooperation Corporation [Laughter]
it was my shock but I don't have any friends
what no you remind me of my brother now follow
me I need to know more about this crack Stone
so we have a meeting house to break into give
me a retainer what why your teeth are really
good not as straight or white as in it but
still
foreign [Laughter] bud I'm not sure what secret
crack stone is hiding but I have a strange
feeling the answers to my future lie in the
past
the Dominic West wants to bet this crack Stone
figure still alive in some way [Music] but
that's the girl she saw it's young Weems codex
umbaram that's Latin for Book of Shadows Blair
Witch too great the fake no hold the fire
to it or something serious but I doubt she
was an outcast settler okay maybe it's fake
you'd make a killing on Etsy I proclaimed
the meeting house is under repair that book's
a replica you don't say the original was stolen
last month during the two o'clock witch trial
the original Meeting House the one shown in
that painting where is it how the hell should
I know I only moved here from Scottsdale in
April oh how now can I help you
walk out with it okay yes damn get a lot of
money for that do you think squirrels and
rats could ever work out I mean they're two
totally different species I mean totally why
not maybe mutation and evolution I was thinking
of sneaking behind the greenhouse tonight
supposed to be a blue moon only happens once
every 23 years or something crazy should get
a killer view from there she's so good by
the way you you know that's where a lot of
kids go to hook up right oh my god dude
oh that's what you were doing yeah so you
want to meet up behind the greenhouse tonight
yes or a date
yes I can't believe he asked I love her she's
she yeah she could be a freaking star she's
so shy you want a coffee one of the many perks
of this wonderful assignment I'm actually
here for Tyler I'll kill him you know the
original Pilgrim Meeting House the one from
the sixth look it's kind of sketchy squatters
and meth heads use up places to crash pad
my dad has to clear it out every couple weeks
what's this about the meth OD I gotta make
it a score yeah
if I could take you this afternoon with my
shift ends at two I know my way around the
Great Outdoors tell me you were a Girl Scout
I can eat Girl Scouts for breakfast I'm sure
we're having Uncle who went to prison for
that Easter eggs
what's blue lighting I love it yeah Sleepy
Hollow witches in there
thing would work I think the pacing gets better
every episode I was expecting more too nope
use the words little one girl to address me
again and I can't guarantee your safety
thing a hand here
[Music]
no I can't just touch something my vision
seemed to happen spontaneously they're not
you have to learn to control them Wednesday
Adams I bet this will give us some real inside
foreign
got ideas for dinner though [Music]
great transition [Applause]
oh no she was burned you're a witch Wednesday
Adams
you have been judged before God what's your
what's her name good was it goody the goody
Adams something like that we were here before
you leaving an army with the nature and the
native Folk but you have stolen a land you
have slaughtered the innocent you have robbed
us of our peaceful Spirit are the true monster
all of you [Music] whoa yeah did you get him
the devil has sent such a demon
and I will send you back
Pilgrim world does not look fun [Music] set
it away oh guy does make a great evil pilgrim
I don't know if that's like Jenna Ortega's
younger sister or something leave me say something
he's trained us all to the
[Music]
boom oh then just find the others and save
our future
foreign
what a crazy Vision she's tapped into here
yeah
oh
spooky whoa there will be no Escape for you
she looks so badass in the rain must have
been the bearded man from earlier
Tyler you uh want some coffee [Music] just
tell me who it is uh the footprint's getting
smaller
you saw it all right bind this misleading
[__] I know what I saw I'm trying to keep
an open mind how big
I texted him again today said maybe we could
meet up over spring break and go snowboarding
like we did last year said he wouldn't be
able to make it you never went snowboarding
last year part of me wanted to blame his recent
weirdness I did think it was almost like they
went snowboarding yeah so I've lived with
the cell ular and the first thing they'll
tell you the psychic Visions can't be trusted
they only show you one part of the picture
he gathered all the outcasts in the meeting
house and burned them alive okay he was a
sadistic [__] I mean a mass murderer cracked
Stone was standing in the quad you're creating
a story in your head and using Visions to
back it up they're telling you what you want
to see are you mansplaining my power well
actually I would warn you that psychic ability
isn't rooted in logic it's triggered by emotions
and let's be honest the motion isn't exactly
your strong suit so yours must be a little
more reliable actually someone has repressed
as her would have a lot of emotion it's obviously
Tyler I don't buy a g we've built a monument
to celebrate his memory now may the spirit
of Joseph crackstone be memorialized for eternity
yay [Music] [Applause] it's great seeing him
in front of the white church after all that
with the water good inversion [Music] oh damn
what's going on [Music]
oh the revenge
the revenge
dude still asleep [Music] I'll come a Wednesday
I would react a little bit yeah come on [Music]
although I'm with you oh yeah it's cool [Music]
I love it I love it [Music] Let It Burn Let
It Burn [Music] sweet
you're already on thin ice I swear on my late
scorpion soul my hands are clean [Music]
the family hand on the other hand why does
this town even have an Outreach day don't
you know it's real history without casts I
do to an extent then it might be complicit
in its cover-up those who forget history are
doomed to repeat it well you see do I see
opportunity maybe this is a chance to rewrite
the wrongs capital is perdumity
Who the hell's there
why is he killing him it's a really good burst
why why why kill the guy He Knew Too Much
such a life
wish me luck if he breaks your heart I'll
nail gun has
[Music]
is going on here this is a classic piece of
music
I see you normie one coincidence is just a
coincidence two are a clue three are proof
[Music] ah so subtle oh no no no no no dude
no no oh
great that's why you don't get stoned in the
shower [Music]
tragic three coincidences that I know are
connected
[Music]
yeah enjoy that crumple that did it better
is this it uh what's the song I've been trying
to figure it out this whole time I I hear
this I hear the tune Cornell and Christian
enlisted a band earlier trying to give us
that one Fleetwood Mac is it Fleetwood Mac
no I don't know dead monster could be anymore
huh oh damn all the normies aren't as Normy
as they appear
the truth is there were Monsters Everywhere
oh that's morbid the monsters we suspect are
the most dangerous [Music]
they hide in the shadows until no one is looking
and then they strike no Christ
and I won't stop until I [Music] ooh
[Music] that's a weird looking bear but I
guess that's what it has to be [Music]
[Music]
oh he's seen that creature before yep yeah
you say that crazy oh he's seen it he's seen
it never care for what they do that's right
man he knows he knows the Beast all right
that's Chit Chat springboard us would you
I am really enjoying the progression of this
show I feel like I feel like you know in the
in the vague amounts I have heard of the discourse
everybody kind of agrees that the first episode
you know needs a little it gets smoother from
the start and that's been my experience I
think that's definitely been echoed in some
of your comments as well over this and yeah
I've really been enjoying just the descent
into and the immersion into just the tone
of the world that they've drawn you know there's
the mystery and all that stuff and there's
The Quirk and everything but just I don't
know the way that they realize this Duality
between Nevermore and Jericho I think has
been really fun and really nice and just a
place I've over these three episodes now I
just kind of look forward to spending time
in so uh so yeah I've been really just kind
of enjoying the the progress thus far and
if I'm not mistaken is that uh are they I
suppose this could be another mislead but
did we just essentially learn that Xavier
is in fact the Beast I think it's a hundred
percent of mislead yeah why do you have scratches
on his own neck that's true see that that
makes sense scratching himself he probably
tried to intervene and Tyler's probably mad
that somebody who is close to Wednesday slash
and also a peer saw him maybe that's what
happened I don't know we haven't really learned
what Tyler's deal is why he's in therapy why
he's suffocating himself in the bathtub and
then letting out an anguish scream why can
you answer that I can't I think something
to do with the fact that maybe he's got a
monster ability sure and boom shakalaka accidentally
kill mommy and even Sheriff Donovan Galpin
was like God damn that boy that boy ain't
right yeah he's on uh because because isn't
isn't the doctor the therapist Valerie I thought
she only works with I I don't remember well
enough I don't remember it does but but yeah
they're never more people she certainly does
work with never more people but I don't know
if it's an exclusive thing I don't recall
you know what just hit me that that uh oh
I hit you mother for a minute my brain was
like what do I do uh the the woman in the
Uriah Heap shop is uh is disa from the rings
of power yes thank God yeah God you got that
totally cool so cool yeah just one of the
highlights of that show 10 out of 10 rings
of power yeah uh yeah yeah I think it's uh
it's it's starting to bleed a little bit political
which I like yeah I like it I like that I
don't know much too much about Pilgrim history
you know it's a it's a dark spot for me I
don't really know too much just a lot of piousness
and tolerance hmm I'm speaking as a as a arm
chair I know a couple things you know I don't
I don't know I don't know too well it's I
don't know what other than what they show
here of like sure with that kind of [__]
yeah I mean you know you think of colonization
and you think of you know yeah Draconian religious
practice that led to things like The Witch
Trials but also you know uh nasty colonization
practices that leads to stealing and burning
and pillaging and all sorts of other things
okay so I know enough you you know enough
I mean I'm sure there were actual Pious people
just trying to set up peaceful encampments
and you know live peacefully but yes I mean
in the in the spread of you know the the early
uh settlers Across America you know you bring
in a lot of uh yeah a lot of taking a lot
of uh disease and a lot of Destruction well
I thought this episode itself was paced at
the pacing I think consistently gets better
and more absorbing I like the escalation of
her psychic abilities because I don't agree
with this whole Xavier sentiment that he can't
trust them when I'm like she went on a full
on transportation thing this wasn't some quick
flash of images that was uh unclear Mystique
this was a full on I have practically time
traveled now yeah to this spot in time and
it's it's interesting to learn all this uh
inclusion of Witchcraft enhancing The Addams
Family Legacy they had a line in there the
secret society about a normie who died like
some odd years ago is that what they're saying
Gomez Adams did is that the is that the worry
murder maybe the murder yeah because they
have some mystery set up here and I'm trying
to make sure I don't lose track of everything
I did feel the um the because I really like
the way this episode progressed and I I really
loved the uh the how to for just for lack
of a better word just how dark it got it got
really dark by the end and I love the moodiness
of it and it was very much like a Netflix
binge thing where you have the last episode
with this really great Cliffhanger and then
it's kind of absolved really fast with some
she knows everything already the university
knows like way too much for any Wednesday
Adams yeah she's already not tied up and she's
not provoked whatsoever and it's just kind
of silly yeah and I I kind of wish that sort
of milked out a tiny bit more it was one thing
about that scene that I wish was had some
kind of maliciousness or Menace or someone
or may or at least made you believe there
was an actual threat credibly before immediately
you're putting you just back into the environment
you're already in just with new clothes and
a new Atrium that's like one little thing
that if I was binging this I probably wouldn't
have even thought about it since since we're
reflecting on the episode that's like one
thing I wish I craved I craved a tiny bit
more of that but I really felt the ending
notes even when it's like melancholic Montage
of everything at the end because like the
way they've introduced this city has been
so bright and beautiful and prosperous but
you know there's a underlying Darkness that's
just percolating throughout and now we have
this ending conclusion of all kinds of mysterious
figures you got the mayor it's clearly a greedy
son of a [__] got the principle uh Gwendolyn
Christie who is fun to see her uh chew up
some scenery in a role like this you know
and then of course with Xavier whose performance
has been growing on me every episode and uh
Enid who I think is fantastic and I like how
she represents as in a school full of teenagers
she's the one that feels the most like a teenager
yeah the one who where the powers that she
has with in her like which were cat werewolf
something like that um the those abilities
just whatever the monster that's within her
I don't mean Monster in a negative way which
is whatever the monsters that's within her
seems to come out via metaphor adolescence
I think she does such an excellent job and
uh the effects are really good too the Medusa
head guy oh yeah it's great yeah the Gordon
that was great um yeah there's a lot of really
cool stuff and the therapist is even a kind
of mysterious figure as well
yeah I have a a spooky Taxidermy in fact I
would never have a Taxidermy I think that's
uh messed up it is unless you go out into
I guess yeah depends on how ethical is ethical
taxidermy I don't know you know like this
here is portrayed as being ethical Taxidermy
like oh this this rat was hit by like a car
or something I haven't we haven't I have a
neighbor who has a big buffalo head oh yeah
I don't know how I think oh that can be but
uh no I really like their scene together uh
Enid and uh and yeah the the Gorgon dude uh
I'll find his name for you John I have an
IMDb right in front of me don't you worry
John that guy he looks like the one of the
dudes from trick or treat but I think he's
too young to be him I have no idea who it
is um can't see his name Jackson Ajax yeah
it's Ajax um Enid and Ajax that scene they
had together I thought was really fun too
because I thought they could have you know
I mean there's a bigger fish to fry in the
scheme of the plot but I like they that's
an example of a scene where they really just
cut to the chase like I love that Enid is
just like I have been trying to like drop
these Anvil size hints on you and uh and yeah
that was like super sweet and endearing and
uh those especially her but like the way that
they they I think there's a good point about
the Montage at the end because as much as
this is Wednesday's show I think they have
done a nice job at making it an ensemble and
making everybody at least interesting and
intriguing so yeah to have just that life
expanding now and it's like okay we have had
Ajax as a part of things up until now but
this is the sort of most we've gotten to know
him a little bit um and so I like that too
that with with each episode you get to know
just who's around a little bit more you get
to know a little bit more about the surrounding
characters and two like uh Miss Thornhill
uh you know I love that Christina region is
here anyway but I also am excited to see her
part of the mystery unfold I don't know like
she is the the the quintessential like I bet
you're not actually ignore me because they
make so much out of you being ignore me but
there are a few people like you know the like
Ricky Lindholm and uh some other characters
who are pitched that way I feel like part
by the end almost probably like all the normies
are probably gonna be not normies and maybe
that'll be part of the point well I think
it sounds kind of degrading Normie yeah sure
you know yeah it does it sounds a little degrading
sure I'll stop using it I'm sorry yeah this
is this is the wokest thing Tim Burton has
made so far so I should be in more in line
with that sure sure uh I think Tim Burton's
direction is really great and the music's
really solid yes this was this felt I want
to call this episode of filler because it's
certainly advancing the plot in every way
um but yeah but this it also is setting up
a different type of Direction I think where
the Ensemble is more fleshed out in a way
that feels really intriguing and I like the
I like the cinematography of the pilgrim World
a lot it felt very Wednesday it felt very
Adam's family and just the designs and everything
too oh yeah put it in black and white too
it's just the just the world of it and the
b-boy I think is really interesting to have
Eugene uh to have him in here because they
call it out they're like you remind me of
your brother and he does feel like the surrogate
for Pugsley it's just kind of strange when
I'm like got a whole show out they got yeah
they have a whole pocket character who already
exists world and I guess puglies is doing
fine at normal schools yeah probably he's
probably getting bullied and [__] yeah
um but I wonder if her connection with Eugene
by the time she I'm assuming reunites with
her family by the end of the story will you
should probably hug him you know oh give that
Pugsley a hug pug hug around here a hugsley
yeah I want to see more Yoko because her name's
Jacob yes this is yeah there are there are
a lot of uh interesting characters around
who seem to just fill things out and they're
not all white which is nice I imagine the
carrot the least white Tim Burton joint as
well is it surely people have a lot of problems
with that actually I've discovered in recent
years this is he just doesn't have a lot of
people of color cast in his stuff and are
arguably that's because he loves the I'm gonna
make you so pale you're essentially like pure
white look um but you know it's like General
Ortega's 100 caucus well no and I like that
they embraced that here too like you had her
you know goody Adams among the various she's
not yeah yeah yeah and I don't know exactly
what her ethnic background is but you know
like she's Mexican yeah like there's assume
there's a lot of there is South American and
Native America and Native North American crossover
there and stuff like that and so for what
this is you know and and expounding on a character
Mexican and Puerto Rican okay see yeah yeah
um and and not to say that not to conflate
them as being the same but I like that they
at least utilized that aspect of their casting
and I don't know like I feel like I look back
and the sort of ethnic Side Of The Adams Family
is is never felt like one of the more engaged
elements and it's not like the point here
but I did like the way that they had that
flesh out the vision the flashback the moments
with the pilgrims it made sense not only because
Wednesday and the Adams lineage are you know
strange and and sort of outside the Norms
of whatever time they exist in but also based
on something foundational that is you know
I don't know for a story like this it makes
sense how you would have you know a traumatic
you know historical event in the family then
pass itself down you know it is interesting
that Tim Burton did Miss Peregrine's Home
for Peculiar Children which in some ways is
him sort of getting his feet wet with a world
like Nevermore sure yeah you know what I mean
yeah and uh and and Frank and weenie took
place at a school Dark Shadows they're all
ethnic in there all of them throw ethnic they're
also okay all the black people whatever and
that's the other thing I was like and I'm
not gonna make a real issue out of this but
I was sitting here going okay like the mayor
is kind of a phony crooked guy who's helping
prop up like you know trim like you know crappy
history by what he does and you know uh the
siren girl is you know queen bee adversary
and whatnot and uh the mayor's son is kind
of a dick he did Planet of the Apes Michael
Clark Duncan plays in April that's true woke
Tim Burton forgive me it started during planet
of the day karaoke tagawa I'm gonna tread
played Crow I'm gonna tread very Softly on
the Apes oh God what Apes joke nothing there's
nothing no no off-color jokes to be made here
that I will definitely not engage with right
he doesn't do a lot with ethnic people not
even to say that I think it's like an intentional
thing but but it's nice to note like oh man
look guys like there there's a very diverse
cast of Wednesday nice yeah well we got that
out of the way well guys um I am kid there's
one thing I want to look up sure uh it does
look like her but it might just be like spot
on the thing is you're Undertaker looks Latina
whereas that girl um in the past the witch
goody Adams she looks white there's that blonde
hair just want to see here it is because sometimes
they do that thing where they're like let's
let's get your cousin or your sister's sibling
yeah I want to just see who plays her let's
d a jeweler that's right up there oh it's
it is her where Jennifer oh she plays her
yeah oh yeah it wasn't 100 sure because of
the height I was yeah I mean I wonder if they
did any any like really subtle because because
I think with younger people you know there's
it's just more subtle when they have to doctor
stuff well she did such a good job that I
did I thought it was I really was just like
is that her sister yeah um no I mean I wasn't
100 sure like I was I was pretty sure but
not 100 sure damn because she speaks a little
differently so convinced that it was a white
girl [Laughter] it's a white chick nah it's
just that blonde hair oh damn that's wild
yeah good to know yeah and and yeah and and
like the the subtle little Showcase of range
there is nice well guys what did you think
about this episode of Wednesday I liked it
quite a bit um I'm really really enjoying
the show a lot quite this is this is a really
good show it's a joy uh leave your thoughts
down below uh subscribe leave a like and hey
let's send this with a pig
Adelia Chamberlain I know Thanksgiving was
rough I hope your Christmas was better and
I hope 2023 treats you a lot better absolutely
in some ways I could see you being like a
Wednesday Adams you know some type of Injustice
pops up and maybe you don't really like dealing
with people too much but you would still want
to do the right thing and solve the problem
anyway because you stand up for what is wrong
a good moral compass you are the true peerer
of heart exactly exactly so Adelia I hope
that this 2023 presents you with a lot more
opportunity and a lot more blessings because
Lord knows you freaking deserve it more than
John and you do I hope it's bad it finally
pays off so I love you dear and I look forward
to talking with you some more and I hope that
you have a fantastic rest of the year and
hit me up anytime we'll talk [Music]